the scenes inside the al-aqsa mosque in
occupied east jerusalem early friday
morning
[Music]
fighting between stone-throwing masked
men and israeli police who fired stun
grenades and tear gas
[Music]
around 150 people were injured
this palestinian cameraman was there
they brutally emptied the compound they
were attacking the mosque staff normal
people elders young people
there were many injured people they
fired rubber bullets inside alexa mosk
compound they were beating everyone even
the paramedics they hit them
israel's foreign ministry tweeted dozens
of masked men carrying hammers and pa
flags marched into al-aqsa mosque the
crowd collected stones and large rocks
police were forced to enter the grounds
to disperse the
crowd the al-aqsa mosque is islam's
third holiest place it's also revered by
jews as the site of the original temple
as such it's often an epicenter for
tension between israel which controls
movement to the site and palestinians
especially during the muslim holy month
of ramadan
this time last year fighting around the
mosque and axis restrictions led to an
eleven day war between israel and
palestinian armed groups in gaza
so far this year a series of attacks
within israel have left 14 dead and
israeli security forces killed 20
palestinians during raids of the
occupied west bank
after the violent confrontation israeli
forces restricted access to al-aqsa
mosque but then a few hours later they
did reopen the damascus gate where we
are now which is one of the main
entrances to the old city al-aqsa mosque
and its compound are deeply important
and symbolic and with ramadan easter and
passover all happening right now
tensions in this city and its holy sites
are set to remain high john holman al
jazeera occupied east jerusalem